la lettre de l'an 2000 mg à nos jours
depuis actualité oblige d'un grand
couturier celui qui a sans doute le plus
anticipé sur le 21e siècle paco rabanne
ses prédictions sont tout à la fois très
alléchante vous allez l'entendre mais
aussi à peu terrifiante tout de suite
paco rabanne la caravane 43 ans le plus
futuriste de toute la haute couture il
ne ressemble à aucun de ses confrères la
veille de son défilé
il ne prenait pas de crise de nerfs et
finissait paisiblement lui même la robe
de mariée mes confrères dis toujours je
ne suis pas un couturier
je suis un artisan et c'est vrai je suis
un artisan dont je ne peux je ne perds
jamais au calme ne fait jamais de ma vie
mis en colère je travaille de mes mains
je réalise la moitié de modèles ont peu
de mal parce que les films peut pas le
faire c'est trop difficile les anneaux
sont très dures comment est ce que vous
avez une unité de fermer rendement mais
qu'à la négative à noël c'est à dire que
le mode pour moi n'est pas un monde
inconnu puisque ma mère que leur
première chez des enseignes en espagne
1920 peut-être m'insuffler mon goût de
révolte parce que en 1920 est la
première fois de sa vie bastia en
espagne à porter des robes de power paul
poiret sans corset et les cheveux courts
ma mère a fait de prison parce qu'elle
était scandaleuse
habillé de façon scandaleuse parce
qu'elle vaut mieux voir les créations de
sers de mes confrères et la honte et dj
pro t130 c'est grotesque et n'ont pas de
courage et faits de jeu plus agressif
à 18 ans il entre aux beaux-arts où il
étudie l'architecturé 30 ans il obtient
un prix pour sa sculpture habitable
grâce à la couture pour gagner ma vie en
travaillant en fils on hésite et de rose
art j'ai vendu des accessoires add your
brain siaka givenchy saint laurent à
tous mes confrères j'ai vendu j'étais
accessoiristes chez eux et un jour je me
suis dit que la mode pouvait aller plus
loin encore et plus brutale plus
significatif mais proche de l'époque
jeune homme pour moi dans un pot
excessivement médiévale agressive
brutale c'est pour ça que j'essaie de
faire des offres qui représente cette
époque une cote de maille pour les
femmes se protègent contre les
agressions qui se multiplient il a
travaillé dans l'atelier d'architecte de
benjamin perrin qui lança le béton armé
le béton de pakosz et le jersey
d'aluminium le plastique cette année un
nouveau tissu ignifugé nouvelles façons
d'enduire le tissu de métal pour le
rendre
la platine inflammable et qui vient
c'est une technique de l'aviation et
cette année tous mes motos sont fait
anti feu quand vous croyez que les
femmes ont tellement l'occasion de
prendre seul la vie savez moi je crois
que l'amour du prophétique et le mode
annonce de futures le futur pour moi est
une catastrophe c'est le feu qui se
répandant sur nos coûts surtout surtout
les gens car venant d'architecturé où
j'ai appris beaucoup de choses sur deux
symboles et sur la prémonition en face
pour le les architectures qui marque le
temps qui annonce des temps à venir le
moment légalement est un signe des temps
quand la nature se médite sur les
vêtements époque puritaine le grand
krach de 1930 a été annoncée en 1927 28
par l'événement très long très étroit
sombre qui annonçait déjà ce krach
puisque l'événement s'allonger tout va
mal mais quand l'événement
raccourcissent tout va bien mais par
moment même c'est vraiment en avance
quand les lettres les cheveux des femmes
dont les régimes tombent à l'avant
chaque évolution habille les femmes en
tête qui confie qu'elle est sur le
fameux je le dise tout va bien les
régimes sont stables bail actuellement
il ya de plus en plus deux types
d'événements que l'on prendra la
collection s'ils sont les vêtements de
la superposition ça l'avenir la fuite
la fuite devant catastrophe est
l'événement mais nanti feu devant leur
catastrophe se prépare on t'a dit
recette applicative et je fume un taux
qui nous font croire aux camions écoutez
je suis médium je connais ton bien très
bientôt des prophéties des temps à venir
et de temps en temps quand je me promène
dans la rue à paris je veux je m'arrête
place est tellement les hurlements des
gens très vif sono mes oreilles avec un
impact pour l'hiver prochain
non il ya encore une bonne dizaine
d'années afin d'imaginer la manade savez
si la mode continu est rétro comme ça
chez mes confrères je crois qu'elle a
peut-être 1965 à l'an 2000 en l'an 2000
haute couture
ça sera chaude interne archéologiques 20
ans périt mine complètement balayées
histoire il ya peut-être un retour
violent imprévisible d'artisanat et il
n'y a plus de couturier viendra des
arguments qui créeront dans des petites
échoppes comment ménages événements
spéciaux à la main qui son père est
encore plus extraordinaire que
l'événement dans le futur aujourd'hui en
l'an 2000 on travaillera - tout mon
travail mais beaucoup de choses là on
passera du temps de travail en temps des
loisirs
et comme l'événement évolué avec le
geste physique l'utilisation d'un laser
la peur je crois qu'il éradique de
concelles du vêtement vire le vêtement
de travail la femme porte rade
combinaison d'événements travail un
petit peu à sexuelle puisque ça sera
l'événement fonctionnel
oui il ya déjà le bout jean il ya de
plus en plus de pantalons également dans
les collections de couturiers qui
prévoit déjà ce temps de travail
et puis il y aura le temps de faiblir et
en espagne le plus grand où la femme ne
redeviendra super papillon
extraordinaire avec d'événements de plus
en plus d habiller fantastique un peu
peut-être la grève ou comme certains
costumes égyptiens qui étaient des
voiles transparents aux plissés tissées
d'or
ça sera une autre paire femmes je crois
que l'on entende mis la femme aura
mystérieuse maquillage extraordinaire et
sera maquiller le corps entier ont déjà
ces crèmes à bronzer
on applique au pinceau et ben on vendra
des crèmes de rudes et crédibles les jo
ouvert et c'est pas le maquillage
extraordinaire irréel sur des événements
des voix cette transparence
alors vous croyez qu'elle se feront des
peintures de guerre comme les aguias où
les africa ce nom mais comme deux
heureux que reuben comme les estrades
pour le pétrole que tout un peuple
depuis l'hôpital et jusqu'aux pieds pour
vous au milieu de toutes ces
catastrophes
comment vous voyez dans dix ans du haut
possible de l'hyperactivité si vous
pensez que dans une dizaine d'années
venait de disparaître dans les flammes
pourquoi êtes-vous continue
et à mettre vos petits anneaux autour
des perles et et à faire des robes de
mariées plein de tunes passent et qu'on
vide
il faut libérer des survivants beaucoup
seule main